germany goes to the polls shortly in a
crucial national election
three candidates are vying to replace
angela merkel who's stepping down after
a remarkable 16 years as chancellor and
it appears to be an open race
merkel has widely been seen as a key
global player during her four terms in
office
but she leaves behind a germany mired in
crisis climate change corona pandemic
afghanistan are all casting a dark
shadow over her departure
so on to the point we ask the crisis
manager departs what comes after merkel
[Music]
well thanks very much indeed for joining
us today and my guests here in the
studio our casting gamalin from the
german daily called the zoo deutsche
seitung or
she says it looks like germany is going
to be governed by a three-party
coalition but whether that coalition
would be led by olaf schultz is still
very much an open question
also with us is deutsche bela's own
chipon de chimbello a senior editor and
commentator at dw he believes that
voters face a really tough choice after
all he says the future direction of
germany is at stake
and a warm welcome to tumultum from the
berlin-based target spiegel newspaper
who argues that it's quite possible that
even on election night we won't know who
will be germany's next chancellor the
difficult task will be to form a new
coalition government
casting first question to you uh i saw
her recently described as the eternal
chancellor but it is not so angela
merkel is now finally departing how much
are we going to miss her
i think um
that we we will see that only when she
left first of all but uh i think in
terms of politics
i'm not sure that will will that we will
miss her a lot because uh how we can see
now at the last decade of her
of her chancellor being a chancellor is
being in the chancellor is full of
crisis yeah
but personally i must say for me angela
merkel was not only a the chancellor
of the united
germany but since i'm coming like her
from the eastern part of the
country so for me she was also
the woman that came from the east that
that knows the interests of the east and
we have not seen her governing for the
east of germany but for the united
country there is no doubt about that but
i was sure that in her head and in her
thinking she always took also the
interests of the
of the former gr into politics and i
think that i will gonna miss from the
next because the three candidates
none of them is from uh from these they
are all from uh western germany that's
very interesting
chiponda angela merkel we might i think
miss her more than we actually imagine
although in the past year or so her her
legacy her record seems to have been a
little bit tiny seems to at least have
lost a little bit of its shine
is that fair comment i think that's a
fair comment i definitely think that
whereas she is sort of a uniting uh
figure person a personality for germany
and a lot of people see that and feel
that
and she's been great at managing crises
what she hasn't done is really create a
vision for germany to go forward with
and um
that she hasn't done a good job
with and a lot of people have realized
and recognized that that she hasn't had
a vision for what germany should look
like in the next five ten years even
post her era and i think that's part of
the issue with her leadership she's been
great at managing crises and finding a
lot of compromises in certain issues
but what is the vision what is the
future and she she hasn't really done
that for germany what is the vision what
is the future
there was a chance that helmut schmidt
who's always said who needs vision and
politics should go to the doctor
so i'm not quite sure if we really need
a what you call a vision we saw a a
crisis manager
who was very modest
deeply informed about the substance of
politics and about the substance of the
topic she has to deal with
and uh but we didn't see a a crisis
solving
personally i mean all these crisis if
it's the european union ukraine corona
you can't solve the corona
saying is crisis this whole crisis
management thing was a myth
no not the managing thing but solving
the crisis is something else i mean um
you you put the the the european or if
it's the greek debt crisis or if it's
the the split between west european and
eastern european countries and so on you
just put it on hold she's accident
putting crisis on hold but not insulting
but the question is just can you solve
the european crisis as a person i mean
you need a majority to do so immanuel
macron would say yes yes in germany you
always say no
exactly that's exactly what i mean
because macron clearly has a vision
clearly has an idea yeah but you have
his vision and does he have the majority
i mean that asks the question that is
the question and where you would need
merkel perhaps
yeah exactly and that was actually the
big mistake
macon had a vision when he came into
power as a president of france and
merkel had was really able and she has
she is able to find majorities and it
was really a pity that she did not that
two of them could not find together so
macron was waiting for her to
to give answers to his questions and
mark just stayed in the chancellory
saying um perhaps and she didn't do
anything on that you're completely right
but i think the the next step of the
answer would be we won't miss her
because all possible successors
are clearly
following in her try to follow in her
footsteps
because they don't have radical
different politics a different agenda
things like that so
so yes we might miss her as a person but
not her politics okay let's go back to
the election itself three parties have
put forward candidates to become the
next chancellor the christian democrats
the social democrats and the greens the
three candidates themselves are hardly
unknowns but people are asking whether
they have the stature to be at the helm
of europe's biggest economy
armin lachet is the cdu's chancellor
candidate
he's been fending off attacks from
fellow conservative marcus serda from
the bavarian csu but remains unpopular
among the conservative party's voting
base he's seen as an optimistic
politician who has however little
charisma
he had a major mishap during this year's
floods when he was filmed laughing in
front of flood victims and volunteers
people who needed consolation and
support
the gaff was followed by a 20 drop in
the polls
a record low for the cdu
annalina
is the green party's chancellor
candidate
she started off strong with her party
even briefly taking a lead
but public trust in her dwindled as it
became known that she padded her resume
and that a book she penned is full of
plagiarism
she apologized but her polling numbers
sank
many people feel vindicated in their
belief that her colleague robert hobeck
would have been a better candidate
[Music]
olaf schulz is germany's current finance
minister and the spd's chancellor
candidate the former hamburg mayor is
seen as rock solid
but boring
his inner party rivals are mainly
left-wing members of the spd but they've
been keeping a low profile
schultz began his campaign with fourteen
percent
but is benefited from mistakes made by
his rivals
now he's considered the favorite for the
chancellery
schultz
lashet or berbach who will succeed
angela merkel
well that remains to be seen but i think
what we can expect from our free guests
is that they're going to give us a
little bit more color if if somebody if
people coming from abroad looking at
germany interested in germany what do
they need to know about the candidates
and about the election that's coming up
what is vital
maybe we should start with annalina
bairbach uh the green candidate we we
heard some some
about her life biography her problems
in the beginning because of plagiarism
switching in the biography too much she
had a very great start
in april when the greens came up like to
20 in the pulse
but then she suffered a lot of setbacks
and some some really personal attacks on
her own
and what speaks in her favor is that i
seem she survived all of them she became
even a better statue out of it
what speaks
again is is the topic of climate change
we all saw the flooding in parts of
germany and so the topic of climate
change is it's in everybody's mind
so uh the big question is just looming
it could she go on one with the
ratchet
erdogan with vladimir putin with the xi
jinping nobody knows
but that has to be seen
but i would like to remind that when
merkel came into power in the
chancellery in 2015 uh 2005. sorry uh
then the former chancellor schroeder
said what this person she can't do she
won't do it so just and now we have seen
that michael did it she was back then
she was now where she where and elena
berbock more or less is now more or less
yeah yeah okay michael had already she
had already won the election but more or
less in a situation
in which people say oh she cannot do it
but let me come to olaf schultz uh this
solid candidate which many people say
he's a very boring you have observed him
very closely yeah i was following the
last four years when he was finance
minister i was with him in the u.s uh
seeing him talking to janet yellen or i
saw him in the bundestag and
in other or in
venice g20 so i have seen in
seen him a lot
and i must say he's reading a lot of
books and he's talking a lot to people
in his environment
and then he is making his taking his
decisions from reading and from talking
to others
and he's a very solid guy
he joined the social democratic party
already when he was 17 i think
and
so he is a marathon man
so he has a very long career already he
had it already in politics and if you
look back for instance when he was the
mayor of hamburg
he got the party together the social
democratic party he did win two times
the election there and in terms of
housing which is a big problem in
germany now he did very well and also
for kindergarten and other things so
people know when
they elect him they know what they get a
boring person but a
person that is in a way electro
intellectual
but he's quite able to do something a
boring person perhaps a competent person
perhaps a thoughtful person perhaps but
he's also somebody who has a propensity
to sort of
rub up a little i'm being very cautious
rub up with
against the world of banking
finance where he has a lot of
i mean
yes i mean he has uh
some mistakes of course in a long career
he did there were some mistakes also
in the banking world let's say wirecard
many people know about this famous
german entity that suddenly went
bankrupt and to 20 billion euros or
dollars
just
disappeared in the air disappeared
exactly but on the other hand what what
many people think about charles is that
he's doing something against unequality
and let's remind you also that germany
is the country in the world where social
inequality is very high in the western
world and it's growing and many people
think that he is the guy that can stop
that okay very important point uh
chiponda well um
yeah i mean i i get missed the last [ __ ]
and um
the fact is i i mean i used to live in
nrv i used to live in bond before moving
to berlin so i actually was there when
he was failing
and he is the state premier of uh north
wind west valley
and i um i mean it was a surprise when
he won the elections against hannah
laura craft who's running for the social
democrats there so he's sort of the
underdog who might be unexpected you
know who literally delivers unexpected
results and this is sort of what
happened when he was selected to be the
leader of the cdu and also the csu as
you know as chancellor candidate
um in terms of his personality he's sort
of under-delivered so far unfortunately
i mean he has done a good job in the
past but he's under delivered in the
last couple of months in the campaign
and he's not he's struggling he's trying
to
show himself as a worthy
uh successor to merkel and that's part
of his problem because you have merkel
who has been a unifying figure for
germany for the last 16 years and he has
to come up you know to show that he can
follow up to that and at the same time
show how he can be different from her so
he has to be similar to her in some ways
but somewhat different and he's really
struggling to cope with that expectation
and what we saw in the last tv debate of
the three chancellor candidates it was
him pretty much trying to appeal to the
solid base of the christian democrats is
what his final argument was that he
would be this person who would you know
deliver stability and everything that
merkel has done essentially of course
you know during the you know the
discussion in the debate he did try to
show that he was different but in doing
so he was also criticizing merkel uh you
know in a way even though he was
directing himself to the vice chancellor
schultz so that was interesting uh to
watch as well so he he probably has the
toughest
job in the campaign in a way because he
has to
follow up to merkel and that is really
hard so i think he has the the most
difficult job it's sort of you know if
you've seen other elections if you're
trying to replace an incumbent who's
really popular that is really hard i
don't know whether that's the case
because i clearly remember three months
ago the social democratic party had i
think 14 15
and everybody thought oh what what does
schultz do there i mean this is a race
with two candidates yeah exactly and now
suddenly we have three candidates so
basically i don't know whether luschette
was in the most uncomfortable he wasn't
in the most uncomfortable position three
months ago but i think essentially if
you're coming in to replace an incumbent
an incumbent who's extremely popular and
you try to
show that you're similar to that
incumbent and at the same time that
you're different from them because you
are going to improve on certain things
that is really hard because you sort of
have to be in a contradiction in in in
yourself and that is really a tough job
for a person i i think you mentioned the
the the value of stability the
expectation from voters that that in
times of of of of turbulence from corona
to ukraine to climate change and so on
the flooding and so on and so on um the
expectation is who's re representing the
the need of stability and we have
schultz
as a vice chancellor who was part of the
government he is might be the one but
you have luscious as one from the cdu
who is always
uh the party of the chancellor itself
who who represents stability so it's a
race between two persons
both of them are trying to
to symbolize vote for me because i
represent stability that is the top and
bottom of what germans wish for from
from their next government stability
i mean everybody's saying what they
really need is a kickstart they need
modernization they need digitalization
they need a government that's going to
top off stability
but nothing they want climate change and
digitalization and things like that and
i i would say yes they want these things
but but but they are not ready for for
new eruptions societal eruptions and
that's kind of interesting that you
mentioned that because you can clearly
see from those two candidates shorts and
lashed that they are trying to appeal to
this idea of stability and germany
represent instability and not rocking
the boat too much and i think that's the
point and so i think it is something
that they're clearly aware of and
bearbach is sort of the you know the
fresh
sort of something different somewhat she
in her rhetoric is not so much a radical
green with climate change he always
mentioned the social dimension of
climate change policy and things like
that try to go to the middle and try to
appeal uh the feeling of the electorate
that too much eruption won't be uh good
at the time but even that is already too
much exactly i would say i think for
germans that is radical i mean we're
here talking about it
you know
flights within germany being banned or
they say they just want to bad
everything they just want to ban
everything and of course they're trying
to
appeal to the german need for stability
and
sameness if you like and that's what
really they're trying to do i really
missed in the past i must say is that
merkel could have helped lushet a bit
more
i mean why not
that she's going out every second day
saying oh luscious is a good candidate
she could have done that but she said oh
no i don't want to she doesn't want to
steal his thunder yeah but i mean
she's a member of the tdu and now
there's a battle that
another tdo member should go should come
into chancellory why doesn't doesn't she
support her own party member
i mean she could do that oh i think this
we should try to do that by uh you know
clearly calling out shawls for against
um
well him not speaking out against a red
red yesterday
yesterday
exactly
so that was interesting
burning in the party is the first time
she's coming out with that
and that's interesting and i thought
that was interesting that she clearly
called him out and in that way spoke in
favor of uh you know of flashett and was
supporting him in a way without
necessarily saying i'm here and i'm
campaigning for lashed which is exactly
what you would expect in other countries
we haven't seen that happening in
germany so i think for me as a done
german it's always interesting to see
that dynamic and why that's gonna happen
i'm not sure if it helps luscious if
mecca would be more
more backing him uh in terms i mean
they have a good relationship
lashed was the one who supported her
without any conditions in the in the
refugee crisis in 2015 2016. uh the
moment she stands behind him much more
is
the moment he
she takes away
the light from him to her
if they were i mean suppose they are in
public and she has a speech and he would
have a speech whom do you listen to to
merkel
so that that
would
show a contrast between them too i don't
know if it really would help could put
the spot on him
okay let's say i just like to change
gear just a little bit because malta
already mentioned a list of sort of
crises that we have faced in recent
times and it really is a a time of
crisis many people would say let's just
have a look at some pictures there and
talk about merkel's management of these
crises and where
where else we can expect that kind of
management from
crisis number one climate change germany
experienced it firsthand in july floods
in western germany killed at least 180
people and destroyed infrastructure
houses and apartments
now climate change is a central campaign
issue
crisis number two afghanistan directly
following the withdrawal of troops from
a hindu kush the taliban seized power
again
almost 20 years of counter-terrorism
missions by the german army were in vain
terrorism once again poses a major
threat
crisis number three the coronavirus
pandemic the endless fighting between
the government and germany's federal
states made fighting the virus
effectively more difficult
many people reject the rules altogether
refused to wear masks and have protested
in the streets leading to violent
conflicts with the police
will the approach to these three crises
decide who wins the election
what do you say chipotle to that
question will the uh the the who's going
to deal with these crises bessel who can
promise to deal with the crisis best and
how is that going to input impact the
outcome of the election well in terms of
who can deal with these crises best uh
we've seen what the um ruling party the
cdu can do the christian democrats
because they've had to deal with these
crises so far
in terms of proposing something
different i would argue and say that the
greens have at least out from the three
counties are proposing something
entirely different and for the voters
who
are fed up with what the government has
done or are not happy with that
potentially the greens is the way to go
talking about the greens you're talking
about climate change and addressing the
essential threats of climate change and
also social equality those two things
which are coming off the back of the
coronary arteries have a much more
radical much more radical because in
more realistic terms in foreign policy
and then bearbox says we have to get
stronger with russia
more stronger with china and things like
this i'm not sure if the majority of
germans are willing to follow her on
that because they are quite satisfied
with this not unsettled situation in the
ukraine with having to yeah we we sell
our products our cars to china uh don't
anger the bees too hard
so if annalina bearberg really is is in
power and you see these things come
through i'm not sure if the majority of
journalists follow her i i mean
potentially not but i would say that
most people don't vote on the basis of
foreign policy and we know this from
other countries we know this from the
united states of america and i also know
this from discussing i can't vote in
germany but i know this from discussing
this with a lot of germans um even the
ones who are interested in foreign
policy are not thinking about foreign
policy when they're voting basically
exactly and
based on that we are looking at someone
who's going to solve
problems and issues which are sort of
right at the doorstep and that would be
climate change for sure and the
coronavirus pandemic and the foreign
policy is less so on uh
an issue it is an important issue
nevertheless but it's not the the basic
exactly
do i understand right climate change is
going to be the decisive issue in this
in the outcome of this election one of
what i'll say and so
i would say
you can say that climate i mean many
people saw now we have seen the pictures
of the flood and many people are
attacked by climate change now and they
see that and they feel that is real
but nevertheless they say so
even if i sell my car now i take only my
bicycle at the end in my lifetime will
there be a change to the good will can i
really so i i now i i change my life but
the result of what i'm doing can i see
that or is it for my children or for my
grandchildren and so i think people
will not only vote because of climate
change i think that really social issues
in germany
uh what i mentioned already the
inequality and the housing prices you
know there are really housing housing
prices are going up in in berlin you
have seen that in munich in all big
towns so people do not earn enough money
this is a really important message about
germany that people look to germany and
believe that it is
taxing issues taxing issues yeah who has
to pay now for climate change and that's
what you see with these christian
democrats they've said that they've done
a good job of having a stable economy
but what they haven't done a good job of
fighting social inequality and in terms
of inequality within germany it's been
growing while of course people can get
jobs but if your job kind of pays your
rent it's like it's a professional
democrat party meeting no but i think
it's social justice without any doubt
but it's innovation as well i mean what
the lesson of the corona crisis was that
we are quite unprepared in schools and
universities in in entrepreneurs in in
to deal with the digital um
yes
with all these with all these affairs
and that other countries are far ahead
and so i think innovation to be a
competitive in a globalized world is one
of the main topics in the election as
well besides of social justice which is
always a german topic okay on those wise
words we'll have to leave the time
it's been a great show though i hope
we've given you plenty of food for
thought ahead of the election which is
now getting closer by the day it's it's
tense and it's exciting and stay with us
to find out more until next time bye bye
and cheers
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you